[Musik]
mein heutiger gast im dialog ist sie
dazu herzlich willkommen vielen dank
sie vorzustellen ist gar nicht so
einfach sie sind kabarettist bekannt aus
der heute schaut sie sind schauspieler
regisseur musiker tv-moderator politiker
sogar einen kleinen ausflug gemacht wie
sehen sie sich denn selbst das wechselt
ich bin mal das mal dies ich bin in der
regel künstler
das ist die plattform von der aus sich
aguirre und welche form nicht dann im
einzelnen werde das entscheide ich
spontan
wo immer sie sich geäußert haben war das
sehr politisch im all diesen
verschiedenen berufen und berufungen
deswegen rät man doch einfach mal am
anfang über die aktuelle politik ist es
gut dass sich union und spd auf einen
koalitionsvertrag geeinigt haben es ist
ein koalitionsvertrag oder es ist ein ei
ne eiweiß angleichung das ist glaube ich
die bessere frage wir haben ja beide
seiten sehr viel von ihrer identität weg
geben müssen um in diese versuchung noch
mal zu kommen sich die macht zu erhalten
ist auch das wesen des kompromisses in
der demokratie ist auch manchmal das
wesen den willen des wählers zu
respektieren und der wähler hat keine
eindeutige absicht geäußert meiner
meinung nach neuwahlen hätte ich nicht
gescheut ich sehe auch die gefahr nicht
dass die afg stärker werden wird im
gegenteil ich glaube die spd hätte bei
ihrer ankündigung bleiben sollen sie
hätte mindestens wenn sie diese
ankündigung selber bricht die kanzlerin
erpressen müssen nämlich wir gehen in
eine große koalition ohne kanzlerin
merkel
dann hätten wir jetzt jens spahn als
nächsten kanzlerkandidaten und wir
werden vier jahre weiter als wir es
jetzt nicht sind das heißt erleben wir
jetzt dass anfang vom ende von angela
merkel
es wird ich glaube es wird zwangsläufig
passieren dass angela merkel sogar nach
zwei jahren nicht mehr kanzlerin sein
wird ist meine vermutung sie bereitet
ihren abgang vor die nächste generation
der cdu hat es schwer angela merkel hat
alle platt gemacht es gibt niemanden
mehr der thronfolge sein kann
und leute die peter tauber äußerst
farblose gestalten
die werden das ding nicht aus dem keller
reißen also ich sehe schwarz für die cdu
als mal einen kurzen ausschnitt aus
ihrem bühnenprogramm an
jetzt gehört ja zu ihrem spiel das man
nie so ganz genau weiß ob das was die
bühnenfigur da gerade sagt wirklich auch
ihrer persönlichen meinung entspricht
also willkommenskultur uneingeschränkt
positiv nein nein ich habe das ja schon
auf dem höhepunkt dieser euphoriewelle
geschrieben in meiner kolumne in der
wirtschaftswoche dass ich dem braten
nicht recht trauen mag denn ich kann das
war gerade überall zitieren hatte ich
mir nämlich auch geschrieben das kotzt
mich mittlerweile dieser common sense
von willkommenskultur an
gut es ist das wesen einer kolumne da
ein bisschen zu überspitzen angekotzt
hat mich in wirklichkeit nicht aber ich
habe dem ganzen nicht vertraut weil ich
wusste so schnell wie so eine welle
kommt so schnell kann sich auch wieder
verschwinden so schnell wie wir den
flüchtlingen kuchen backen und sie haben
bahnhof empfangen mit freudentänzen so
schnell werden wir auch wieder über
obergrenzen sprechen und genau das ist
passiert viele die am anfang
bedingungslose willkommenskultur
eingefordert haben es gab ja eine
regelrechte hetzjagd auf menschen die
anderer meinung waren haben dann
einsehen müssen dass das problem so
einfach nicht bewältigt werden konnte
oder einfach an die kanzlerin die gesagt
hat wir schaffen das aber nicht erklärt
hat dazu videos schaffen
jetzt gehört ja auch zu ihrem stil dass
sie klartext reden aggressiv laut
auftreten gut aufteilen jetzt in dem
sketch hat er gesehen gegen populisten
gegen aussies gleichzeitig haben sie ja
gerade von einer halben minute ein
ziemliches statement für toleranz
abgegeben wie weit geht denn ihre
toleranz also können sie auch
nachvollziehen dass jemand auf dem ich
kann erst mal alles nachvollziehen ob
ich es gut finde ist eine andere frage
sie haben jetzt mehrere fragen auf
einmal gestellt die erste antwort ist
diese figur die ich dort spiele ist eine
mischung aus unterschiedlichen facetten
sie ist zum einen die überspitzte
darstellung eines populisten auch ich
bin eine art prediger das ganze ist ja
auch eine messe so ist es angekündigt
und ich gehe da an die grenzen des
denkens was ist eigentlich möglich was
können wir alles im diskurs im
dialektischen diskurs besprechen dass
ich dabei manchmal auch meine eigene
meinung äußere manchmal verfällt ich sie
auch manchmal über spitzig sie ist teil
des programms und das hat den sinn dass
das publikum selbst entscheiden muss wie
weit es mit mir geht das andere ist dass
ich persönlich ein äußerst toleranter
mensch bin das heißt aber nicht dass ich
alles hinnehmen toleranz heißt nicht
alles hinzunehmen und alles toll zu
finden sondern teile toleranz heißt auch
manchmal kontrolliert intolerant sein zu
können
das was sie da auf der bühne spielen das
hat natürlich wie bei jedem künstler
wahrscheinlich sehr viel auch zu tun mit
ihrer eigenen biografie sie sind in
istanbul geboren kam als kleines kind
nach deutschland so dieses einerseits
türke andererseits deutschland welche
rolle spielt das für sich es hat lange
jahre gar keine rolle gespielt also bis
zu den 90er jahren kurz formellen waren
wir türken in deutschland eigentlich
integriert andere haben gesagt wir sind
assimiliert worden ich habe das nie so
empfunden ich habe mich als wehrhafter
vollständiger teil dieser deutschen
gesellschaft gesehen nach mölln nach
solingen
insbesondere in den 90er jahren dann mit
den nsu morgen hat sich etwas deutlicher
auch herausgestellt dass wir türken
immer noch nicht in deutschland
akzeptiert werden aber auch dass sie
selbst uns nicht angekommen fühlen
dieser separatismus der türkischen
bevölkerung in deutschland der war ja
die aus meiner sicht falsche antwort auf
die übergriffe und so erforderte diese
zeit insbesondere bei mir eine
neupositionierung leider sie in ihrer
autobiografie der schilder ist es so
eine szene bei der einschulung wie sie
und die anderen in anführungszeichen
gastarbeiter kinder da ausgesondert
wurden also so ganz
wissen sie jetzt kurz mal erzählen aber
auf jeden fall so ganz natürlich war
auch da nicht alles so dass ich hier
wieder in den 70er jahren ich sprach
davon dass wir in den 90er jahren
weiterhin als wir es jetzt vielleicht
sind in den 70er jahren war das
tatsächlich so dass wir türken nennen
wir uns jetzt mal wir türken die wir
alle gar nicht immer so eindeutig
türkisch sind
repariert wurden wir sollten eigene
schulklassen haben damit wir unter uns
bleiben können wenn man einen antrag auf
eine sozialwohnung gestellt hat kann man
in besondere viertel in denen nur türken
wohnen sollten
das wurde alles in dieser
integrationsdebatte die dann folgte
unter den tisch gekehrt denn tatsächlich
waren nicht nur die in deutschland
lebenden türken nicht integrationswillig
sondern auch die deutschen waren nicht
integrationsfähig und insbesondere als
dann bücher bietet thilo sarrazins
deutschland schafft sich ab oder auch
aktiv in die bücher auf den markt kamen
die diese position dramatisiert haben
und auch extrem ii siert haben war es
für mich eine pflicht zu sagen nein die
geschichte der einwanderung in
deutschland ist anders als ihr es gerade
darstellt es ist eine geschichte von
gegenseitigen versäumnissen
wir können uns noch mal ein ausschnitt
anschauen diesmal aus der heute show
oliver welke und serdar somuncu hallo
liebe kinder aus syrien hallo
der onkel erklärt euch jetzt mal wie
integration geht das wichtigste ist
lernt richtig aber nicht so gut wenn ihr
besser deutsch spricht als die
eingeborenen dann fühlen die sich
bedroht
am besten gestreut ihr zwischendurch
immer mal sinnlose setzte ein sieht
alter ich schwul bin mutter du mist
geburt
klingt komisch ist aber so das begrüßt
so wollen die ihre aufschläge ausländer
du das wollte ich dir immer schon mal
sagen wer da so spricht er wirklich
fabelhaft deutsch wo kommt deine familie
eigentlich her aus köln
entschuldigung
[Applaus]
das wird das volk hier falsch verstehen
ich meine bekommt ihr ursprünglich her
ach so aus köln-nippes ja
deutsche ganz wichtig kinder die lieben
es wenn man als ausländer freiwillig
deutsche gerichte ist leberkäse
ausgestellten kniescheiben du magst du
leberkäs ich versuche mich jetzt zu
integrieren du fällst arschloch ja wenn
man die die beiden figuren da im sketch
anschaut die sind ja beide im grund
genommen ziemlich hilflos ist das
wirklich so schwierig ist es begegnen
zwischen bio deutschen und migranten
das kommt darauf an welche phase dieser
begegnung sie meinen die jetzige phase
ist schwierig weil die türken vor allem
sich absondern
die phase über die wir eben gesprochen
haben anfang der 90er jahre nach der
wiedervereinigung war schwierig weil die
deutschen sich nicht damit abfinden
konnten dass das deutschland das neue
deutschland in dem wir alle gemeinsam
gelebt haben ein anderes deutschland
waren
worauf führen sie sich denn zurück dass
das töten sich jetzt zunehmend ab
sondern von der deutschen gesellschaft
oder sich gegen die deutsche
gesellschaft teilweise sogar
positionieren wenn man von das nicht
verallgemeinern aber wenn sie das
ergebnis der der des referendums
betrachten
in meinen um die verfassungsänderungen
in der türkei geht um die
verfassungsänderung gegen als um die
stärkung der präsidialen macht von
erdogan ging da waren einige städte in
deutschland essen mit 73 prozent weit
über dem durchschnitt dessen was in der
türkei einen pro stimmen gezählt werden
konnte das hat mehrere ursachen es wäre
jetzt zu leicht
dem einen oder die anderen die schuld
zuzuschieben aber es hat viel damit zu
tun dass die türken seit den 60er jahren
seitdem assoziierungsabkommen mit der
europäischen union vor den toren europas
stehen abgewiesen werden sich abgewertet
fühlen auch sehr stark immer wieder in
den aussagen wenn sie über erdogan
sprechen mit in deutschland lebenden
türken kommt dieser satz
erdogan zeigt den europäern endlich mal
wer wir sind mehr zeigt eine starke hand
und der ist konsequent eine klare kante
das andere ist natürlich auch das
verstehe ich das richtig dass sie jetzt
erdogan nicht durchgehend negativ finden
sondern dass sie sagen da muss man
differenzierter hinschauen das wäre
jetzt zu einfach gedacht also ich wollte
ihnen erst mal dass eine erklärung
gleich contents ich habe nicht so viel
zeit dass der zweite grund um da auch
ein bisschen mehr neutralität und und
perspektive rey zu bringen ist dass die
hier lebenden türken sich auch
verweigert haben das stimmt ein teil der
hier lebenden türken gingen davon aus
dass es eine kurze zeitspanne sein würde
die sie hier bleiben und so kam es dazu
dass töchter nicht in den
schwimmunterricht gehen sollten oder
dass die sprache vernachlässigt wurde
auf beiden seiten also ist etwas
passiert was dazu geführt hat dass
demagogen wie erdogan die macht an sich
reißen konnten wie ich finde
auf eine sehr fragwürdige art und weise
und ihr publikum gefunden haben vor
allem bei menschen die eben diese
sehnsucht dieses bedürfnis nach der
aufwertung dieses
minderwertigkeitskomplex haben
erdogan hat seine seiten erdogan ist auf
der einen seite für die türkei positiv
weil er die türkei den verhandlungen mit
europa selbstbewusster dastehen lässt er
zahlt dafür einen hohen preis die
investoren die ihr zum beispiel
stattdessen in die türkei holen muss
sind investoren die allesamt aus dem
europäischen aber auch aus dem nicht
europäischen ausland kommen
hauptsächlich banken und versicherungen
und diese wirtschafts blase die sich da
aufgebläht hat in der türkei die kann
von einem auf den anderen tag platzen
zudem ist das verhältnis in der
türkischen gesellschaft äußerst fragil
sie haben auf der einen seite die
kemalisten die in der minderheit sind
die chp mit den parteiführern klitschko
bringt eigentlich keine
oppositionspolitik mehr zustande
sie haben die mhp die radikalen
nationalisten die sich auf die seite von
erdogan geschlagen haben und sie haben
die akp und diese spaltungen der
bevölkerung deutlich spürbar die türkei
steht heute an einem scheideweg zwischen
europa zwischen dem nahen osten und
asien
und wenn wir nicht erkennen dass diese
chance die wir lange jahre hatten die
türkei zu integrieren
in den europäischen einigungsprozess für
uns bald verpasste ist dann werden wir
es mit einer sehr schwierigen türkei zu
tun bekommen
gehen wir mal zurück zur situation der
der türkischen migranten in deutschland
haben da gerade diese szene
gesehen diese krampfhafte hat sich
absurde versucht die eigene
integrationswilligkeit über einen
leberkäswecken zu beweisen zu definieren
gibt es trotzdem eine art von von von
pflicht- oder aufforderung an migranten
sich an so was wie die deutschen kultur
oder gar an eine deutsche leitkultur
anzupassen
na ja die gibt es nicht weil es die
deutsche leitkultur nicht gibt die
müssten sie mir erst mal definieren
ich habe ja das wörtliche erfunden aber
jetzt liefere ich halt mal ein bisschen
vorlage also ich sage deutsche
leitkultur ist goethe und helene fischer
deutsche tradition russin also ich bitte
sie ja das deutsche leitkultur ist
bitteschön dann okay kann er war
bisschen weiter ist deutsche geschichte
deutsche traditionen das grundgesetz
karneval weihnachten oder setzen sie bei
einem sehr anachronistischen
deutschlandbild an deutschland ist ja
mehr als die lena fischer und karneval
deutschland
deutschland ist ein konglomerat aus
unterschiedlichen kulturellen einflüssen
dass deutschland was wir heute haben ist
ein zusammensetzen aus ost und
westdeutschland zum beispiel auch ist es
eh katharina ich weiß nicht wie frau
fischer mit wirklichem namen reisen die
ja nachweislich russin ist es sind hier
lebende menschen die aus
unterschiedlichen ländern kommen
portugal italien jetzt neuerdings auch
aus syrien aus dem nahen osten das ist
für mich deutschland an deutschland die
vielfalt in deutschland des friedlichen
und toleranten umgang miteinander und
nicht ein starkes deutschland das an
einem bild festhält was ich eher an
deutsches reich anlehnt finde also da da
müssen wir unser selbstbild als deutsche
jetzt haben sie ja ein ziemlich
plastisches bild einer deutschen kultur
der freiheit der toleranz der
weltoffenheit geschilderten 30 mal
umgekehrt also würden wir erwarten dass
sich migranten an dieses weltoffene
deutschland mit allem was dazu gehört
das eben familien nicht patriarchalische
organisiert sind dass frauen gleiche
rechte haben dass menschen ihr schicksal
selber in die hand nehmen dürfen werden
wir erwarten dass das das als leitkultur
oder als prägende ideale werte
akzeptiert ja das ist aber kein
nationaler kodex an dem wir uns halten
sondern ein gesellschaftlicher kodex
wenn es um die gleichberechtigte
behandlung von frauen geht können sie
auch mit filmregisseuren darüber
sprechen dass sie da noch einiges zu
lernen haben
das hat nichts mit der nationalität zu
tun jeder mensch der in deutschland lebt
egal ob er aus deutschland kommt ob er
hier geboren ist ob er originär deutsch
ist oder sich nur so fühlt hat die
einladung an dieser gesellschaftlichen
auseinandersetzung teilzunehmen an
diesen kodex den wir gemeinsam erfinden
müssen
das heißt eine bringschuld dass man sie
noch von demjenigen der akzeptiert
werden will als vollwertiger teil
das heißt aber auch von demjenigen der
es verlangt auch eine ähnliche nennt es
nicht schuld aber eine ähnliche toleranz
seine einladung eine form von offenheit
die beinhalten muss dass sein bild von
deutschland auch revidierbar ist den
boateng ist das beste beispiel wenn
alexander gauland heute sagt ich möchte
kevin boateng nicht als nachbarn haben
dann widersprechen ihm nachweis nicht 80
85 prozent der bevölkerung und darauf
bin ich stolz nicht darauf dass wir ein
deutschlandbild haben was stark heftig
ist was anachronistisch ist sondern dass
wir als deutsche miteinander egal woher
wir kommen woran wir glauben oder mit
wem wir schlafen einen gemeinsamen
nenner finden der uns passt und der uns
gefällt
gibt es dinge die die integration
erschwere auf der deutschen seite und b
bei seiten der migranten das wort bio
deutsche hatte ja ich habe mir lange
überlegt was ich besitze aber
deutschland würden sie sagen sie sind
bio deutschland
ich mache mir doch mal ein vorschlag ist
schwabe das ist richtig komme aus
stuttgart anhänger das war aber dann
machen wir doch mal ein vorschlag was
sie sagen soll
wenn ich darauf abheben will dass der
eine der migrant ist unter anderem
sollten vor allem aufhören über
leitkultur zu debattieren es gibt meiner
meinung nach keine leitkultur das ist
eine geisterdebatte wir sollten uns mit
den fragen beschäftigen die wirklich
akut sind wie integrieren wir die
menschen die jetzt neu nach deutschland
gekommen sind bieten wir in sprachkurse
an fördern wie ihre integration oder
separieren wie sika sanieren wir sie ein
asylantenheim und wundern uns dann
darüber dass diese menschen sich auch
nicht eingeladen fühlen andererseits
müssen die menschen die hier hinkommen
wissen dass wir hier andere werte haben
als sie zu hause
frauen können hier ohne kopftuch durch
die innenstadt laufen
ein mann heiratet in der regel nur eine
frau und nicht 2 wenn das gegen den
wertekanon der menschen verstößt hierhin
gekommen sind sind auch sie aufgefordert
sich zu revidieren und zu lernen
das gemeinsam zu machen friedlich und
freundlich und nicht permanent mit der
arroganz des inhabers irgend einer
übergeordneten kultur
das ist für mich eine große aufgabe an
der ich als künstler politischer
künstler auch gerne teilnehmen können
wir mal zurück auf ihre biografie und
die künstlerin worden sind sie waren das
kind von gastarbeitern in anführung sein
vater mutter waren relativ einfache
leute zumindest war waren die die jobs
relativ bescheiden bergarbeiter dann bei
der müllabfuhr und bei ihnen entstand
dieser unbedingte wille ich will auf die
bühne und die eltern konnten oder oder
wollten ihnen da nicht helfen da haben
sie einiges für einen kauf genommen
haben sogar eine zeit lang auf der
straße gelebt das ist ein bisschen
mythologie siert also ich meine eltern
hatten erst mal das interesse dass wir
alle zur schule gehen und meine eltern
die aus istanbul kommen also kosmopolit
sind waren sehr darauf bedacht dass wir
eine gute ausbildung haben und dann
vielleicht uns verwirklichen
aber eben nicht diese ausbildung
unterbrechen um irgendeinen vagen plan
einer selbstverwirklichung zu verfolgen
und da war ich genauso auf
ständig und so anarchistisch wie jedes
deutsche kind auch das hatte nichts mit
meiner herkunft zu tun genauso wenig wie
die ablehnung meiner eltern gegen diesen
eigensinnigen weg etwas intensiver
hergerissen zu tun hatte
wenn sie sich das istanbul der 60er
jahre anschauen es gibt heute viele
dokumentationen dann werden sie ein sehr
aufgeschlossenes istanbul sehen dann
werden sie überrascht sein wie
europäisch dieses istanbul in den 60er
jahren schon war und sie werden sich
genauso wie ich darüber ärgern wie
rückwärtsgewandt ist heute manchmal
genügt sie haben sich ihren traum
erfüllte die bühnenkarriere ist gelungen
den durch bogdan haben sie geschafft
indem sie adolf hitler auf die bühne
gebracht haben muss man glaube ich ein
bisschen erläutern
sie haben passagen aus hitlers mein
kampf vorgelesen karriereplan erfüllt
wenn ich nachts um 0 uhr bei phoenix
laufe mich rechtfertigen muss dafür dass
ich leicht gut du dich mag ich weiß ja
nicht wie ihre karriere planen außendreh
wenn sie ihn jetzt hier mal darstellen
wollen dann sagen of war phoenix der
richtige ort ist sein erster schritt mal
gucken ich habe keinen karriereplan ja
noch mal zurück zu adolf hitler haben
denn die zuschauer reagiert darauf dass
das sie hitler vorlesen
ich habe schon anfang 1996 also
unmittelbar nach den anschlägen solingen
und mölln weil ich eine reaktion darauf
bringen wollte eine künstlerisch
reaktion und die vorlage die ich mir
gewählt hatte war die lesung von helmut
qualtinger aus den 70er jahren
der berühmte österreichische
schauspieler der vor mir schon aus mein
kampf gelesen hat und es war in der
ersten phase viel entsetzen viele
überraschungen viel zuspruch auch in der
zweiten phase anfang der 2000er jahre wo
ich dann sehr viel in ostdeutschland war
insbesondere auch in städten die
verrufen waren als rechtsextreme nester
da war die reaktion eher na ja ich würde
mal sagen verhalten aggressiv bis sehr
ablehnend
in der dritten phase also kurz bevor ich
dann auch aufgehört habe war sie mir zu
positiv da wurde ich gefeuert ohne dass
ich etwas gesagt habe und so habe ich
diese sehr erfolgreiche projekt was mich
ja auch tatsächlich bekannt gemacht hat
wohl oder übel verlassen müssen um ein
neues projekt anzufangen
ich würde jetzt nicht so viel über adolf
hitler reden wenn sie dieser diese
person hitler nicht eigentlich durch
ihre ganzes leben begleitet er also sie
haben so was wie eine autobiografie
veröffentlicht die heißt der adolf im
meer
sie sind jetzt gerade am theater in
konstanz und inszenieren data boris meyn
kampf also warum ist hitler so wichtig
hitler ist nicht wichtig aber hitler ist
allgegenwärtig hitler ist auch in der
deutschen gegenwart noch eine figur die
reizt die verlockt die abschreckt die
angst macht schauen sie sich den erfolg
an von timo wermes buch er ist wieder da
das ist vor drei jahren vor vier jahren
gewesen es war ein bestseller der sich
mehrere monate in den charts gehalten
hat es ist ja auch in ordnung das ist ja
teil der großen verantwortung der wir in
deutschland gerecht zu werden haben dass
wir uns immer auch in gegenwart und
vielleicht auch eine zukunft mit diesem
thema beschäftigen werden denn es ist
nicht ad acta zu legen dadurch dass man
ein zeitmaß erfindet und sagt so jetzt
haben wir die 50 jahre oben
jetzt reden wir gefälligst über was
anderes sondern es ist für uns weder
hypothek noch belastung sondern ich sehe
es als verantwortung an die wir im
gegensatz zum beispiel zu anderen
ländern wie der schweiz in österreich
belgien holland in denen gerade
rechtsextremismus dramatisch stark wird
haben und die wir auch einsetzen können
als bewusstsein deswegen sie schildern
das so als wäre das für mich eine
belastung im gegenteil ich freue mich
darüber dass ich diesen zugang habe und
noch mehr freue ich mich darüber wenn
ich diesen zugang vermitteln kann
ich würde gerne nochmal auf diesen
buchtitel zurückkommen der der adolf in
mehr
soll das heißen dass in jedem von uns
ein massenmörder strecken leyen aber das
phänomen hitler ist ja ein phänomen das
sich zusammensetzt aus den einflüssen
die es erst zu einem phänomen haben
werden lassen mit la ist ein ganz
gewöhnlicher junge gewesen irgendwo in
thal geboren und groß geworden aber das
was aus hitler gemacht wurde also auch
die zugabe des volkes das dazu nötig ist
dass ein diktator es diktator werden
kann
das ist das was ich meine mit der adolf
in mir schauen sie sich die heutige welt
politik an
wir haben donald trump an der macht ein
mann der pathologische züge hat wir
haben in korea einen diktator wir haben
in der türkei ein zumindest
fragwürdigen autokraten an der macht wir
haben überall in der welt wirklich
seltsame gestalten die unser die unser
leben bestimmen und das was ich in
diesem buch beschreibe ist dass aus
diesen einzelnen essenzen diese
gestalten manchmal sehr gefährliche
einzelwesen entstehen kann
die all diese fähigkeiten in sich
vereinen und diese historische
koinzidenz die letztendlich hitler hieß
die kann sich meiner meinung nach
jederzeit wiederholen und der anfang das
zu vermeiden ist den hitler in sich
selbst zu suchen modi zu eliminieren
nazi ein gern genommenes schimpfwort in
der politischen auseinandersetzung also
woran erkennt man denn ein nazi oder
umgekehrt
wo macht das sinn jemand das nazi zu
bezeichnen und wo ist es einfach nur
eine sinnlose keule
das ist ein argument das ambivalent ist
also es hört sich ein bisschen nach hfg
sprecher
wenn sie mich das zu fragen nazis erst
mal nicht verunglimpfen weil nazi
definiert werden muss auch in dem
kontext in dem man es sagt nazis für
mich derjenige der nazi texte spricht
wenn leute wie alice weidl wenn leute
wie frauke petry bewusst darauf setzen
dass sie missverstanden werden wenn
leute wie poggenburg von der af de oder
auch viele andere analogien zu einer
sprache bringen und selbst bernd lucke
der verhältnismäßig gemäßigte
vorsitzende der afd
der von einer entartung in der
politischen debatte spricht also wenn
leute diese terminologie verwenden und
ganz genau wissen dass sie zwei deutlich
dass sie missverständlich aber sie ganz
eindeutig in bezug zu bringen ist zu
nazi zitaten dann ist das für mich ein
berechtigter vorwurf den man ihnen
machen muss dass sie mindestens mit dem
feuer spielen dass die nazis sind das
wäre mir zu weit gegriffen um nazi zu
sein braucht man ein bisschen mehr
hässliche konsequenz als alice weil es
hat jetzt sind die die person die sie
angesprochen haben alle nicht hier und
können sich auch nicht während die
würden vermutlich sagen sie wir werden
da missinterpretiert
die die frage für mich ist bewirkt man
etwas löst man etwas aus wenn man wenn
man leute die
an anders denken anders wählen
vielleicht eine partei wählen die sie
persönlich für sehr gefährlich halten
ob man da irgendetwas positives auslöst
wenn man die eben mit seinem etikett
bezeichnet weil er nicht die menschen
die diese partei wählen die tun mir
ehrlich gesagt leid denn sie werden
verführt und sie werden irregeleitet
wenn sie sich anschauen was die afg nach
der wahl für ein theater abgeliefert hat
sie hat sich beworben um mandate im
bundestag um sich einen tag nach der
bundestagswahl wieder aufzulösen frauke
petry hat mittlerweile zwei mandate
zusammen mit ihrem ehemann insgesamt
vier mandate von denen sie eines gar
nicht nutzt sie es parteilose im
bundestag sie nutzt das andere
wahrscheinlich halbwegs weil sie hin und
her fährt und wozu dann soll ich diesen
leuten glauben was sie mir vor der wahl
als ihre glaubwürdigkeit verkauft haben
das ist ein falsches spiel mit denen ihr
geleiteten sehnsüchten auch der menschen
die dieser partei ihre stimme geben
jetzt haben sie ja in dieser sendung
wieder bewiesen klare politische meinung
sie haben auch einen ausflug in die
politik schon mal gemacht wäre es nicht
weil sie waren der spitzenkandidat der
satire spaßpartei die partei als
kandidat kanzlerkandidat bei der
bundestagswahl 2017 war das nur und spaß
und da können sie sich auch vorstellen
ich gern die politik nein ich würde das
nicht mehr machen weil es tatsächlich
eine mischung war es war der versuch von
außen aufzuzeigen wie manchmal politik
läuft und wie man auch mit satirischen
mitteln diese grenzen verwischen kann
der ernst der aspekt war dass ich mich
um ein direktmandat in berlin kreuzberg
friedrichshain beworben habe
mitkonkurrenten die weder politische
inhalte hatten noch hatten sie die
ambition wirklich jemanden überzeugen zu
wollen
wenn sie sich anschauen was da auf den
plakaten stand weiter so wir sind die
besseren also anderen leiden erkrankt
bei uns stand wahrscheinlich das gleiche
nur dass wir den satirischen aspekt
vorher schon zugegeben mit 13,7 prozent
der stimmen mit 13.700 wählern 72
prozent der stimmen lag ich zwei prozent
vor der ard anderthalb prozent vor der
fdp
und alle die uns vor
offen haben insbesondere mir ich würde
meinen politischen freunden die gar
nicht meine politischen freunde waren
stimmen wegnehmen wurden eines besseren
belehrt wir haben für eine auflockerung
aber auch für eine bereicherung des
wahlkampfes gesorgt sowie martin
sonneborn der im europaparlament aus
meiner sicht die klügsten aber auch die
witzigsten reden hält das war der dialog
heute mit serdar somuncu herzlichen dank
und ähneln informative informationen
gute information bei phoenix
[Musik]
[Applaus]